et c'est vous Cyril bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation c'est
l'un de nos grands dossiers de cette
journée vous êtes chercheur associé à
l'Institut Jacques Delors spécialiste de
la Russie et des relations aux
internationales alors c'est vrai que
depuis hier on s'interroge beaucoup sur
l'origine de ce ou c'est combattants
s'égroupent comme on dit qui ont
contraint hier des centaines de civils
en russe à fuir leur habitation à la
hâte un groupe on l'a vu à l'instant un
groupe antipoutine la Légion liberté de
la Russie revendiquée sur télégram
l'incursion en question je vous propose
d'écouter
ce témoignage il y a Ponomareff il est
leur porte-parole représentant politique
il souhaite qu'on le présente ainsi il
s'est confié aujourd'hui à Marc Perelman
dans l'entretien du jour il contestent
avoir été écrasé par les forces russes
et par le plus tôt vous allez l'entendre
de nouveaux gains de territoire écoutez
[Musique]
je pense que l'une de nos principales
victoires et que personne n'a été tué au
combat de notre côté nous n'avons pas
perdu un seul soldat aux dernières
nouvelles
l'opération conjointe entre la Légion
liberté de la Russie et le corps des
volontaires russes contre actuellement
une région de plus de 40 km de large le
long de la frontière entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine et on progresse à l'intérieur
du territoire russein
voilà pour un court extrait de cet
entretien vous pourrez découvrir
l'ensemble d'intégralité à 16h45 heure
de Paris sur nos antennes retrouve aussi
sur notre site internet Cyril Bret
bonjour je me tourne vers vous c'est
vrai que les heures passent et on en
apprend un peu plus sur ces hommes qui
ne sont pas nouveaux il y a des
mouvements évidemment on le savait qui
sévissent notamment qui agissent dans
cette zone frontalière ce groupe qui se
revendique un groupe russe dit-on qui
agirait contre le régime de Vladimir
Poutine ça ça fait partie des premières
questions qu'on se pose est-ce que ces
hommes n'agissent pas finalement sous le
compte de Kiev de voldemerzuelinski qui
avait évidemment dément tout implication
aujourd'hui vous vous me parlez de ces
uniformes c'est important de regarder
effectivement l'image comment sont
équipés ces hommes vous me parliez à
l'instant d'uniforme
ukrainien oui cette légion liberté pour
la Russie est une est un groupe qui a
été identifié assez bien en Ukraine
depuis plusieurs mois
qui serait constitué de nationaux russes
qui agirait dans le sens des forces
armées ukrainiennes mais qui resteraient
un groupe d'irrégulier dispose des
uniformes
Ukrainiens classiques mais ils n'ont pas
d'un signe ukrainien ils n'ont
d'ailleurs pas
identifiés quand on les voit comme ça
exactement et les informations qui
circulent à Kiev c'est que ce serait des
soldats russes qui se seraient rendus
lors des premiers mois de l'offensive
russe contre l'Ukraine et qui par
conscience politique serait passé du
côté
ukrainien apprendre sous toutes réserve
en revanche ce qui est certain c'est on
le voit aujourd'hui à travers les images
à travers les déclarations recueillies
par Marc Perelman c'est un groupe
paramilitaire irrégulier qui porte le
fer sur le territoire russe contre le
régime de Vladimir Poutine et contre
l'invasion de l'Ukraine et ça ça change
évidemment beaucoup sur la bonne
stratégie qui sur la donne politique la
question aussi qu'on se pose c'est
équipé de quoi et par qui on a vu hier
alors au départ on nous parlait d'une
simple incursion ça s'est étalé quand
même sur deux jours on a parlé d'intense
bombardement qui ont quand même
contraint neuf localités russes à
évacuer ce n'est pas rien c'est
d'ailleurs l'incarnation la plus
importante depuis le début de ce conflit
oui on en est pas la première incursion
en territoire russe en revanche de cet
ampleur là oui que ce soit réel ou non
40 km de 40 km² contrôlé donc dans cette
zone qui est entre la Biélorussie et le
bassin du dambase c'est important en
tout cas dans la communication militaire
dans la communication politique les
pouvoirs publics ukrainiens et le camp
ukrainien dans son ensemble essaye de
montrer que la Russie est vulnérable sur
son propre territoire et attaqué par ses
propres ressortissants ce qui fait que
ça change complètement la narration en
fait de l'invasion russe en Ukraine ça
n'est plus une confrontation entre
les Russes et un régime
ukrainien c'est bien une confrontation
politique entre les partisans et les
opposants du régime de Vladimir Poutine
et de sa politique étrangère y compris
les Russes Vladimir Poutine ira a
commenté ces événements et c'était
extrêmement préoccupé par la situation
dans cette région préoccupée à quel
point exactement c'est l'union nationale
c'est la fameuse union sacrée que les
pouvoirs publics russes essayent de
créer depuis le début de l'invasion donc
février de l'année dernière mais depuis
le début de cette politique
ukrainienne de la Russie qui aboutit à
l'annexion illégale de la Crimée à la
déstabilisation durable du bassin du don
depuis 2014 donc ce qui est en jeu c'est
vraiment l'unité nationale derrière
cette politique d'agression contre
l'Ukraine et si des Russes voient que
d'autres nationaux russes
son prennent les armes à la main sur le
territoire national au régime de
Vladimir Poutine ça peut changer la
donne dans la popularité du président
russe dont on sait qu'elle est réelle et
très importante on a vu quand même dans
dans cette préoccupation exprimée de
Vladimir Poutine quand même un aveu de
comme un aveu de faiblesse en tout cas
c'est vu comme ça d'ici est-ce que c'est
dans dans son intérêt à lui de
reconnaître que la situation en quelque
sorte lui échappe un peu là-bas à court
terme oui puisque ça justifie une
mobilisation supplémentaire à long terme
non dans la mesure où je suis à peu près
sûr que la propagande russe va diffuser
des messages selon lesquels d'une part
ce sont des traîtres à la patrie d'autre
part ce sont des déserteurs et enfin et
surtout il a c'est avéré ça n'est pas
des suppositions l'origine des deux
corps francs irréguliers qui mènent ces
opérations d'incursion irrégulaire on
pourra origine l'extrême droite russe
nationaliste donc en fait il y a deux
mouvements effectivement l'un qui les
gens liberté pour la Russie que vous
avez mentionné et le corps
des volontaires russes qui lui a son
origine dans les vétérans de la guerre
dans le don de base et qui sont tous les
deux très tracés vers les mouvements
ultrasnationalistes et fascisants russes
de sorte que à moyen terme la propagande
russe va annuler l'effet que ça peut
avoir en renvoyant comme l'avait fait le
président russe dans les premiers jours
de son invasion en renvoyant l'Ukraine à
un régime néonazi un mot de cette région
la région de Belgorod en quoi est-elle
si stratégique ce n'est pas un hasard
s'il frappe là-bas ces hommes comme
toujours pour cette guerre faut prendre
la carte au nord vous avez la
Biélorussie avec des efforts depuis
plusieurs mois pour préparer une
offensive depuis la Biélorussie qui est
au contact de Kiev et à l'est vous avez
le don de base qui est la région
stratégique pour les communautés russes
et pour les communautés russophone et
qui après les revers subis par la Russie
devient le principal but de guerre
maintenir la domination sur le don de
basse et élargir cette domination et ce
que fait cette opération qui n'aura pas
de résultats militaire qui vont changer
la donne c'est de montrer qu'entre ces
deux zones et bien le territoire
national russe est vulnérable donc c'est
fait pour fixer des forces sur le
territoire russe au moment où les deux
grandes offensives de printemps se
profile vulnérables et en même temps je
vais me faire l'avocat du diable on
montrait hier c'est ces images de nos
confrères de la BBC s'écarte avec ses
remparts on va les appeler comme ça qui
ont été constitués par les forces
rousses les forces russes depuis 15 mois
ils sont barrécadés les Russes ils ont
renforcé leur position sur ce sur ce
front est à l'heure où l'on parle chaque
jour de cette contre-offensive imminente
est-ce que vous vous estimez que la
Russie soit en position de faiblesse en
difficulté réellement en difficulté non
au sens où elle ne va pas perdre dans un
à court terme elle ne va pas perdre son
gain territoire c'est gain territoriaux
illégaux dans la mesure où elle s'est
barricadée des ls ou l'avait rappelé
dans le dans le bon basse elle s'est
barricadée au sud pour protéger
l'annexion de la
c'est beaucoup plus sur le plan
stratégique et diplomatique que la
Russie est en position de faiblesse dans
la mesure où plus le temps passe moins
son avance son invasion paraît légitime
ou légitimables et donc c'est beaucoup
plus sur le long terme et sur la guerre
d'usure que même l'Union européenne
grâce à sa politique de sanction qui
vont être renforcés que la Russie est en
position de faiblesse c'est ce qui
explique peut-être on va peut-être voir
les images ces allers retours notamment
chez le voisin chinois le Premier
ministre Roye sont là après tout à
l'heure est aujourd'hui à Pékin Mireille
mitchustin qui a salué tout à l'heure
lors d'une rencontre avec son homologue
chinois des relations bilatérales d'un
niveau sans précédent face à dit-il la
pression des sanctions
occidentales les anciens rivaux
chinois et russe qui renforce on le voit
chaque semaine un peu plus leur relation
diplomatique et commerciale tout ça
c'est le résultat évidemment de cette
guerre en voilà un revers diplomatique
et stratégique avant la guerre la Russie
pouvait jouer sur les deux tableaux
l'Europe d'un côté la Chine de l'autre
et maintenant la réussite se trouve dans
les mains de la Chine merci beaucoup
Cyril Bret vous êtes une affirmité du
jour merci beaucoup pour votre éclairage
à l'heure où la situation n'est donc
semble-t-il toujours pas stabiliser dans
cette région de Belgorod